hey guys welcome to my kitchen today I
decided that I was gonna cook something
that I knew I couldn't mess up but
anything is possible
today we're gonna make some pancakes
basically all I have to do is follow the
directions on the box and if I do
everything correctly we're gonna have
some really tasty cakes so first things
first we're going to read the back of
the pucks okay two cups of original
Bisquick not a sponsored video just when
I think pancakes is what it's like when
I think of start ingredients until
blended
Oh blended not a problem
two cups wait
two eggs one cup nope one cup milk okay
let's just let's just do this just quick
just quick in here really chunky oh and
you got two of those wonderly cakes this
will make and you go a little extra for
flavor stir ingredients until blended
all right now I need the milk the eggs I
know that this is not a this is this is
a dry measuring cup but it's what
happens when you don't not about that
majoring life and then we need our two
eggies in you go and now we stir this is
supposed to make 14 pancakes now we've
got our ingredients all prepped in our
blender it's time to blend look here we
go
there's not a pancake button on here as
there should be
hmm hmm
I think well the problem is there's a
lot of problems yeah see here we go
we've got some stuff that's just stick
into this bottom let's just do it a
little bit more
all right I think things are looking
real good this is looking up things are
looking up here pork slightly less than
1/4 a cup foals on degrees cigarette oh
oh we need grease we need to grease the
griddle this is gonna be where the magic
is gonna happen depending upon how
quickly you want to go into cardiac
arrest it definitely depends upon how
much butter you want to use today I'm
feeling well feeling like maybe tomorrow
morning take a nice trip to the ER and
you get plate clear plates make
everything look a lot fancier and a lot
less messed up than it normally would be
so we're gonna use a square plate for
all of our completed case feels warm to
me I think I'm not sure for thinner
pancakes increase milk 1 and third
custard all blueberries on how many
little chocolate chips at first cake
it's going down Nancy alum timber one
single cake
a single cake is now cooking it looks it
looks like an actual pancake should look
like if when I think about a pancake
cooking when I look at this box this is
what I see this is what I see I think I
did something right you look great
keep cooking I'm not yet skilled enough
to put more than one cake on a pan at a
time so we're just gonna take this
really really slow trying to think of an
appropriate song to sing for this moment
in time that I can't which is
unfortunate hurry up oh my gosh I can't
believe it I think this might be the
most perfect cake for this cake I quit I
quit I'm done that's a lie
okay I'm gonna attempt something that
only professionals attempt and obviously
judging by any of my past videos you
guys know that I am a professional so if
I make this flip Rachael Ray whoever
else has cooking shows call me I and the
best at everything I'm the best at
everything
self-proclaimed softball claimed I think
it may be fun are you guys getting this
are you seeing what I'm doing okay I
think this might actually that's really
hot okay we're done with you let's let's
move on to another one one cake I can't
believe I'm doing something right to
cake oh you're not looking so good yeah
one big kick
well hurry up hurry up hurry up
hurry up this is a problem with making
big cakes in cakes take time we could do
together yes we do
oh sorry little GoPro I hate you Kristi
I think you're real crisp oh my goodness
look at this have you seen skills better
than this
no what you over there all right we
still have some more batter left it will
just make a few little guys cuz this
might cook faster maybe I'll make like a
a shape
is gonna be like I have no idea are you
guys ready for the big flip put your
hands in the air
say something I'll make you pancakes
okay are we done yet how many of these
freakin cakes 14 cakes how many cakes
have we made guys not 14 that's a little
baby cake it came like the actual
pancake I'm sweating right now I was
sweating I'm gonna try to flip all four
of these together here we go we're
making we're using all this
this sounds like something from like the
Ghostbusters like do you remember
actually was that Mario the old original
Mario and Luigi live-action movie this
looks like something that they found
down in the sewers oh that movie made me
fall in love with John Leguizamo I like
Luigi I know I never choose you when I'm
actually playing the game but in life I
choose you know oh man oh this is so
good last no taste test right now taste
test
tell me what you think
one okay well I mean what's the verdict
right they're really good
I'm gonna meet a lot of them this one's
not so good but it's okay but uh thank
you guys for watching this was my
attempt at making pancakes I think I did
actually a pretty good job cuz you know
what it tastes good
hate like butter but I like butter let
me know what you guys think I should
cook in a future episode just leave me a
comment below and tweet me or Facebook
mirror Instagram comment me or something
I don't know I'm gonna go one eat all of
these see you later